- We're celebrating the men
and women serving our country.
And you grew up in a military family,
I was talking to your sister, yeah.
- I did!
- Yeah.
- My mom was a Drill Sergeant.
My...
- [Kelly] How'd that go over growing up?
That's gotta be hard!
- Tia and I are very disciplined,
I will tell you that.
(audience laughs)
And my dad was a First
Sergeant in the Army, so.
One thing I will tell you,
we know how to clean!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause they did not play.
- Oh, my mom wasn't in the
Army, but I know how to clean.
- [Tamera] I heard that!
- Yeah.
- It's a skill now.
- Toilets, like, everything.
- Oh, did you have to do it
with the toothbrush though?
- I didn't do the toilet.
No, they had the little...
They had a brush.
It was really just like a brush,
but it was... It's wrong!
You know what happens in there?
You know what happens... (laughs)
- Um, yeah!
- I earned my roof and my bed.
- Yes.
And every task, it didn't
matter how big or small,
you put the same effort into it.